hello and welcome to this video from out
okay
mmm got black against this Nydia 3G 3
setup and I'm always happy about getting
me five if you get a full center with
black on the 5m or move four things are
going in the right direction at least
you cannot really complain cause it's
nothing special but it's comfortable
okay
what's white doing here trying to take
and pressure rise and pressurize them at
the pawn on 25 take on d5 put something
to see fall let's see
okay I take on before I take on d1 I
play we should be three I take the for
pawn huh is that the solution to
everything in this position
probably not
yeah I will still do it
now he's got rooked is seven thats it's
definitely true and what I see now is
and I should have seen that before I
went should this whole thing tonight
beehive is extremely annoying if I don't
take a fall right away
aha it was really not good ouch
okay
hmm now as truly dislike to get into any
sort of trouble against such harmless
openings I was like more than more than
unnecessary Bishop c5 is the knowing
move him and I'm absolutely willing to
believe that there are better ones yeah
maybe this is one of them okay mm-hmm
come over here
I mean if Bishop c5 now I at least had
bishop f8
hmm you know be three years yeah yes so
not nice to face
yeah I kind of have to do it I mean it's
well it's not what you want to do I
might be six at the end is just
absolutely terrible
hmm I just might be six was strong I
mean but okay this might be might be
good as well
and one day I'm overlooking something
because anyway I cannot just have no
moves in this horror position but in
what is stupid way of playing earlier
amazing
taking on a FOIA should be three what's
what what a stupid way of playing really
now it's doing it's quite some strange
things have it the position is so bad
that the probably still wins
I could have taken you for there simply
nine seconds
okay
anyway to get to get to this I need to
get on the second ring
then I'm somehow causing him problems I
is playing this in a bit of a weird way
really is and if you miss the night it
spin I had to understand
it's his so lucky that he the team that
he is not losing this and probably then
it was a loss at some point I'm very
certain actually and they had a debate
or something it's evenly that was
absolutely weird what he did put the
King into this made on h3 if I'm not
winning here man it must be winning him
just utterly utterly weird Bishop g2
made in one oh yeah I mean I was
actually looking at this for a moment
that's the absolute worst ever
it's a Ganymede I mean
[Music]
[Music]
now again let's let's try to be somewhat
calm about it okay so we had a fairly
normal opening and yeah yeah okay it was
just bad to take I mean this is just a
bad decision something normal
this is going to be fine but this
particular like you did that is just bad
just totally terrible but what I had
missed is I wanted to play the move like
that but Knight b5 was just yeah it
covers this and c7 is is hanging it just
terrible which is a bad idea anyway to
get to allow the rukon 2027 but yeah
this is just totally lost and he could
have won in many ways very easily and
for example he had 96 wins I mean I'm
sure you can resign after Knight b6 and
he played rook c1 I have no idea why
after this ever had only never moved I
mean I don't even have a means I mean
okay it's so bad that
everything winds basically when he
played it ok enough up to this point but
then he gave me many things I can now
allow this yeah yeah I should probably
just take you for immediately my TA
should take g5 ok yeah of course yeah no
clue what this is all about and yeah
anyway I get this somehow get this oops
sorry
if someone decided to give me give me
this is these chances and put the King
back on the edge of the board like here
it's already clear that my counter play
is very strong mukajee one was already
already winning
then g5 I simply did not see that g5
Bishop g2 is made I mean there was a
terrible blind spot and can I keep
clicking like an idiot you this g5 here
you just I'm threatening mate I mean
nothing more nothing less
and he's already completely lost down
and I don't make I just don't play the
maid yeah and Here I am losing which I
actually saw that this is just a couple
of checks and it doesn't lead anywhere I
just made I mean everything what can you
do if you don't play made in one you
know why you don't win the game
ok yeah thanks for watching